hello there it's update day in fortnight
once again and there's a handful of new
map changes and hints to the future
storyline of fortnite that we need to go
through so sit your butt down for five
minutes press subscribe to help me get
to two million subs and let's break down
week 9 of chapter 3.
[Music]
it happened a new poi has been added to
the fortnite island over in the mountain
ranges on the west side before today
this spot was a snow-covered hilltop
with a single chest spawn and now things
are different io have successfully
drilled all the way through from the
underside of the island while we had our
back turned and created the grotto 2.0
covert cavern is here
this place is stacked out with weaponry
enemies and the return of the keycard
vault to get inside you'll need to take
down a new miniboss io's gunner do you
remember what happened the last time we
saw him i'll give you a second yeah of
course you remember he was in charge of
pulling the lever during jonesy's
interrogation this didn't go too well
for him after the foundation used his
face to turn off the machine in game
he's a bit more angry and he also has a
few super powers too so maybe it's time
to get both the npcs together in game to
see who really would win in a fight
between gunner and foundation who's your
money on anyway once gunner is dead the
vault is yours for the taking and wow
look at this place unbelievable amounts
of loot which without a doubt will make
covert cavern a place to seriously take
the sweats away from tilted towers the
oil facility has a few other tricks on
its sleeve around the location are
smaller outposts to explore and some of
these are connected by a toilet travel
system which could be a great way to
loot up or run for your life the silo
tunnel is back again and just like
chapter two we can shoot straight down
and escape through it the io base is
also home to one of the battle pass
skins the ronin he can be found spoken
to and even challenged in a duel this
raises a little question about law as to
whether the ronin is part of io or
allied to the seven or an entity all of
his own we've now seen him around both
factions we saw him playing it cool when
the rock started the chapter and told
the stories by a campfire and now he's
with the io can anyone confirm ronin's
allegiance
the cavern is packed with detail the
dock is jaw-dropping and shows us how
they drilled up to get here and to
expand it's telling the story without
words one of the drills is currently
here and it looks like this poi may be
growing again in future weeks and i'll
keep an eye on it just in case you don't
io are here in numbers and nothing has
been left to chance you can find a
kitchen a gym a shower room sleeping
quarters and even relics from previous
versions of the island this was a
well-orchestrated plan but there's also
a few easter eggs and secret rooms you
should find here away from prying eyes
using the ventilation system it's
possible to locate a few hidden rooms
one has two pc setups gamer chairs
slippers cuddly toys and enough milk and
fish products to last a man-sized cat a
very long time another room has books
and board games and a golden llama is
this giving you thoughts of another
season of fortnite the easy explanation
is that these are all reused assets from
chapter 2 or they could just simply be
an easter egg nodding back to those
times all this could be the first step
in the return of midas and his crew
we've seen hints to sky and meowsals and
the whole place is a giant nod to the
grotto which brutus was once in charge
of on the other side of the map we've
seen midas's golden m and putting all
these things together it could be a hint
to the return of the man in gold that
storyline has so much more to offer and
i for certain would love more midas in
this story
there's a few random things brought in
by this update these were spotted by fn
assist by the way over in coney
crossroads you can find this i have no
idea what it is or why it's here has it
fallen from the sky maybe from the side
of a building or could a hurricane have
put this object here but it was never
reset after the end of the loop whatever
it is it's weird so go hit it until epic
have realized they've made a mistake
also down in condo canyon the dumpling
store is preparing for chinese new year
2022 will be the year of the tiger does
anyone know which animal is their birth
year i'd check but i've got a sneaking
suspicion mine is the year of the rat
and my self-esteem can't handle that
right now
let's go back a week to make sure we
haven't missed anything on our journey
to document all changes on the island
the biggest impact in the last update
was pizza so yeah i decided not to cover
that but also that week there was the
arrival of the third io drill this time
just above the daily bugle this one is
named dash and is the third letter of
five drills which will spell out order
there are two more coming before we meet
again team epsilon will arrive near the
center of the island and finally team
raven will surface just outside the
jonesy location that means io are almost
ready to put their plan into action
whatever that plan may be there is so
many i o npcs on the island right now
they may have the upper hand over the
seven last time we met we looked at a
new npc found south of the second io
drill in the desert biome i mistakenly
thought she was roughing it and it turns
out when i visited there a colombo had
destroyed her home and everything around
it but i went again this week and she
has a lovely building and crops and a
mine to call her home haven's masks are
now available to unlock in-game so
embrace your inner majora's mask or
pretend your caner and start collecting
okay what what is that mask
a little thing that was sort of
surprising over at crackshot's cabin saw
the location remain rather than being
removed after christmas but now look at
it it's been abandoned and the windows
have been boarded up this marks the last
winter decorations being removed
everywhere on the island as snow finally
goes away in the next week or two i kind
of don't like snow so i'm happy with
this but how do you feel about not
having a snow biome in fortnite okey
dokey onto the lore part of the episode
as the season began we've been running
errands for the thickest member of the
seven the scientist it became apparent
that he wanted an estranged member of
the seven to rejoin them to help them
take down the imagined order that of
course is the paradigm last week he sent
out another rocket into the atmosphere
above and once again he stealthily
attempted to contact the paradigm
without us noticing if you haven't heard
it yet here's what he said this time
hey uh
paradigm uh
it will not surprise you to learn that
you remain public enemy number one for
the seven i'm trying to convince them to
welcome you back with open arms but
i can't promise that'll be a cakewalk if
you come back
i'll do what i can and this time i'll
have your back no matter what like i
should have the first time
so something definitely happened to
cause a fracture between paradigm and
the rest of the team i personally
believe it was due to singularity's mech
cracking the zero point all those years
ago but that theory is not proven at all
it appears that the scientist is not
giving up on the only female member of
the seven we know of and keeps
haranguing her to come back every week
so far not a single word from her these
audio logs must be leading somewhere
he's mentioned her five times in nine
weeks so far and if she is the
singularity that exposed monster
skeleton will certainly get her
attention soon and over by the jivara
corpse the audio cues have been updated
again take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
weird isn't it it's just weird right
it's like it's alive under there now we
just need to figure out what the hell is
going on and who is responsible for it
i wonder if the scientist knows before i
go too far into predictions and guesses
let's stick with facts so i'm gonna call
it there thanks very much for sticking
around thank you so much if you've used
code adamaru this week like these
legends here thank you thank you thank
you i'm adam you're awesome i'll see you
next time i'm taking the foundation to
gunner to see them fight
[Music]